[Music]
first of all I never had a dollhouse as
a child we were really too poor my
mother he raised us five of us by
herself but I knew how to make a
dollhouse out of cardboard boxes so I
would make those for myself and my
sisters to play with I finally bought
one when I was about 40 and I just loved
the size and the scale of miniatures I
could decorate but down the carpet in
the wallpaper and everything and that
was exciting but then I'd had two
children my son and my daughter I
thought no person ever loved anybody as
much as I love myself I really thought
that
[Music]
the last time I saw him then when he was
free he was going with his father to be
sized for his tuxedo for the prom and
when I got home I got a call from him
saying he was in jail and I just you
know fell apart just fell apart
and because he had a prior record dan
when this bill is law three strikes and
you're out will be the law of the land
it will be used to put a hundred
thousand police officers on the street
it will be used to build prisons to keep
a hundred thousand violent criminals off
the street it will be used to give our
young people something to say yes to
[Applause]
[Music]
he didn't deserve 167 years he didn't
kill anybody or anything like that so
why would you give him a hundred and
sixty-seven years when they killed
Trayvon and Mike Brown oh my god when
Mike Brown's mother said do you know how
hard it is to bring a black child and
let him graduate from high school and
that really hit because I knew what she
was talking about that's a lot of work
you know my son is still loud my my part
of me is in prison with him mm-hmm
I never know how they're gonna end up if
they're sad you have to give him a sad
face if they're laughing you had to make
them laugh I was little I couldn't do
anything all I could do was think about
my child not eating properly or he had
never even been away from home I had
sent him to camp but it just broke me
down to my knees a thing because I
didn't raise him like that so I I
stopped working I just was very very
depressed and thinking what I should
have done
and finally I thought because I was an
activist in the 60s I thought I had told
them things but evidently not enough so
that gave me the idea to make the Black
History Museum and go into the schools
and explain their lineage we'd they
didn't come from wheat people they came
from people that wanted a brighter
future and suffered a lot to get to that
so that's what I want to tell to you
know people they don't have to join a
game or just be themselves so none of
this is sown I don't know how to sew but
we use tacky glue and that is what's
held all these exhibits together all
these years thank you
[Music]
what the media is showing us and what
they choose to cover is often time not
flattering to young black men and you
can't tell me that doesn't affect them
the way they think about themselves so
my job at them worse to tell them about
where they came from what our people had
to go through to even be recognized as a
human being so we owe them a debt we owe
our ancestors our debt
a lot of times the kids aren't taught
that at home and definitely not at
school so this was my contribution that
took my mind off of the situation with
my son especially in the beginning I
would just go without eating bathing
everything just into it and that helped
me and saved my life I think my husband
he designed these boxes and made sure it
had glass on the top so to like it get
it
I have to have you look back to your
wife
if he was around all the time he's
insane whoo he always wanted my success
and the success of our work so the
dioramas wouldn't have any place to be
if he didn't make the boxes so he can
whip them out like that it's neither
takes all the time
that's just a lot of work
[Music]
this is my old part I can't go to jail
anymore and I've marched I don't want to
do that anymore but I will show them who
they are who their people were and maybe
that'll pick them up
[Music]
I look at these they need me just like
he needed more of it I like for them to
be wherever they can be seen and
appreciating nobody sees them here
that's part of my dream for the future
and my mind thinking about the future we
have a building that we can use and
renovate where we still have the museum
expanded and that I might have a
creative room to work with children and
teach them how to accomplish this craft
maybe have a little library for children
in there
it's a happy place it's a safe place for
families to spend time because this is
not a looky-loo where you can just look
at it and go you have to spend some time
with your child so they will know the
truth just a place where they can come
and learn and have fun read I just see
something for the future that would be
just heavenly
and I believe it's gonna come - yeah we
don't have a quarter but it's gonna come
mmm
that's the children learning steak
[Music]
yeah the waltz
yes you should do the wealthy
[Music]
you